second Hunter Biden IRS whistleblower
comes forward agent claimed he was
passed over for promotion and removed
from tax investigation team for claiming
the president's son was getting
preferential treatment they say a new
case agent who has not been identified
since he was fired last last week
without any explanation after working on
the hunter Biden investigation since
2018 his complaint comes days after it
was revealed the doj removed his entire
team according to his supervisor IRS
commissioner Daniel warfel had told
Congress the agency wouldn't retaliate
against whistleblowers in April
so if you are the son of uh the
president
you get away with committing crimes if
you're the son of this problem right
because because Don Jr couldn't get away
with not committing crimes right like
they were threatening him you're trying
to lock him up for literally nothing
they put his face on Time Magazine
that's wrote red to hand it and he
didn't do anything
you can't catch someone right-handed
when they actually didn't do anything
it's wild but this is how they lie right
it has to be as far as possible from the
truth it's not a small little light it's
not a white lights we caught this guy
doing something right-handed when they
didn't even have evidence because
nothing happened
yeah nothing happened you know who has
been caught red-handed all right the guy
who has pictures smoking a crack pipe in
them that's who's been caught red-handed
look in the look not only did he get
caught handed red-handed the the whole
uh Coalition of intelligence experts got
caught red-handed concocting the story
to cover for Hunter Biden's laptop and
look kudos to Tucker Carlson for
highlighting this in the 2020 election
cycle but frankly it got dropped right
away one of the guys in the middle of
that Tony bobolenski uh came forward did
the interview with Tucker Carlson and
said look if it's Russian disinformation
how am I carbon copied on the same email
uh I got an email we were part of the
same deal flow like how did I wind up
this is true I know this is true and I
told you know everyone at the time look
I know Tony I will vouch for this guy
he's telling you the truth uh and the
story was dead everyone killed it and
you know this is why what happened what
Matt taibi is working on it at Twitter
and the Twitter files is so important
because you see they weren't just doing
this at Twitter they were doing this all
over uh and it might not be the exact
same cast of characters that wrote the
cover story for Hunter Biden's laptop
but it is the same Coalition of three
letter agencies that are using the power
of the government to cancel speech in
America and whether it was political
speech or coveted speech you still think
back to like I mean for me I always like
like uh you know Dwight Eisenhower big
deal at West Point big deal for the
country very successful General uh I
think very successful president and
underappreciated but his Farewell
Address he said you know cautioned
against the military industrial complex
we saw that play out for a long time
used to be the left was anti-military
industrial complex they can't get enough
of it lately but the other thing he
cautioned against was the scientific
technical Elite and if Saint fauci
doesn't epitopize the uh scientific
technical Elite look what was going on
in the midst of all this stuff and at
the center of dominating both of those
are these three little agents disease
canceling and covering and all for
political influence operations for the
left they accused a sitting president of
treason and they targeted his family and
now we have questions about what Joe
Biden's doing and I tell you the way it
feels to me what what it feels like to
me is
this the nation is captured by corrupt
Elites The Establishment that's what we
refer to it as maybe it needs a
different name and we call it the Deep
state but these people don't care about
this country and there's something else
we were talking about this last night
when we we discussed the fall of Empire
the idea was that every 250 years the uh
they say you know Empire's collapse Phil
was talking about this he's like well
the U.S hasn't been an empire for 250
years it's only really since the end of
World War II
I think the fall of the American Empire
would be the greatest thing for the
United States
because the American Empires people
refer to it is this it's it's this uh
expeditionary force that we've sent all
over the world of military bases insane
foreign policy World policing and what
we need to get back to is our own
borders our own people our own jobs our
own economy and that's what Trump was
doing the people who oppose him are
those who want the American Empire they
want war in Syria they want pipelines in
Europe they want to control various
parts of the Middle East and we as
Americans don't care about any of that
but we're so long for the ride because
they're taking us there yeah no it's
very real and one thing you mentioned
about the left loving the
military-industrial complex I mean this
is one of Trump's greatest
accomplishments to be honest that he
pushed the war mongers and the warhawks
out of the Republican Party turned them
into Democrats
yeah look look and this is something
I've said repeatedly about Trump does
not surround himself with the best
people I mean he has really made some
some bad picks uh
as well exactly not sending his best not
all of us picked for bad that's for
certain but it definitely made some
mistakes there however my greater point
is
so many people so many hawks uh were
able to find refuge in the Democratic
party because they said initially or at
least they claim to say we don't like
war and they said you know what
we don't like War but we don't dislike
it as much as we dislike mean tweets I
have a mixed means military industrial
complex because I hated it from 2006
when I found out it existed I've never
known now you love it yeah and now I'm
like well like you know I'm kind of
pro-industrial member if we didn't have
American military bases all over Earth
then what would be the what would be the
other like I had never thought about
like what would be the the other option
if we got rid of the American military
industrial complex well there would
probably be a Chinese military
industrial complex they're probably like
Russian invasions all across and then
that would take so like
I don't like I'm not like just hey
America die I'm not trying to like stop
it out because like what it's so bad get
rid of it like what are your thoughts
yeah look I enlisted in the Army the
Cold War was going on right and you know
people think about the Soviet Empire was
there uh they were the Communists we
were the good guys uh and you know I
wanted to be part of defendant America
and so I look at the time Hunt for Red
October was a big deal the submarines
and the tanks and everything and I was
like I don't want to be in any of those
but I'll jump at airplanes that'll be
great so I wanted to be an Airborne
Ranger I got the chance to go do that I
get over to Germany the wall was still
up I mean we had live ammo on our
vehicles we were prepared for the
Soviets to come rolling over and the
wall goes down I was in um bad toll to
Germany the German Alps in the South uh
training with 10 special forces groups
and this guy stands on the podium and he
goes write this day down this is going
to be one of the most famous days in
history 9 November 1989 and I mean I was
a private so I didn't say this out loud
but I was like oh yeah pretty bold intro
to your talk you know but he goes the
wall just came down and we didn't know
whether he was real or not so like that
Thanksgiving go into Berlin and see
people for the first time I could speak
a little bit of German at the time this
guy could speak pretty good English and
he's like this is it like this
everywhere and we were in the kudon
district which is kind of like Times
Square you know Berlin's version of New
York's Times Square and I was like no
you know we have small towns and
everything he goes no the stores are
open at night and there's fresh milk and
I was like yeah you know I'm trying to
explain like a 7-Eleven or something to
him he goes no and there's like always
food on the shelves and like everyone
can go in because mine was blown I was
like yeah you want everyone to go in
because you saw more stuff but he was
told like we were even more poor than
they were we had two blocks for show uh
and you know the the elites could go in
and get things but you know the regular
people went somewhere else so the flow
at the end of the Cold War was not into
there other than a little bit of sense
of curiosity the flow was how do we be
more like the West you know when I was
in high school Ronald Reagan rode
through my town on a train and I got to
see him speak in Sydney Ohio and he said
said you know a lot of things at that
time one of his famous quotes is
Freedom's never more than one generation
away from Extinction but we're in an era
right now where people say they want
what was on the other side of the wall
they want they come in in Congress and
say they're they want socialism they
want Democratic socialism and I'll just
tell you the place where America is a
Force for good so to your point Ian
um the Korean Peninsula you look South
Korea south of the 38th parallel first
world economy First World Health Care
Mission sending country uh all kinds of
things they're a global donor to help
others around the world north of the
38th parallel they had the other
ideology Paradise yeah absolutely
Paradise up in North Korea that's right
yeah right and there's nothing going
wrong there but for America intervening
the whole Korean Peninsula would be like
North Korea yep and but for China I mean
look what China did we could have made
the whole Peninsula like South Korea but
China stopped it so look we do need a
strong military but we don't need an
Empire I mean I think look one of the
best uh book titles I don't know a
republic not an Empire we what did you
you know the question to Ben Franklin
what have you wrought sir a republic if
you can keep it and the real thing is we
lost our way how do we get back to a
constitution a government small enough
to fit inside that Constitution I'm
sorry or what concerns me is like the
Spanish-American War at the end of the
1800s uh Cuba was controlled by the
Spanish Empire so the United States
decided we're going to liberate Cuba
they did they attacked they they
dispelled the Spanish Fleet they
liberated Cuba they didn't take it we
could have made Cuba American territory
but instead because of the righteous
that we were we we let them become
independent and then they became a
communist threat so like at some point
where the value you of con of being the
one in control of the strength and
conquering and governing the world like
there is value to that yeah I'm just
terrified I don't know no I think that's
that's actually a really good point my
my eyes have been opened we should just
go in and start taking over other
countries right now because we're better
than they are name a country their
economies are usually bad right there's
a lot of crime and Corruption Mexico
boom you know we already fought a
Mexican-American woman we could have but
but the president who was it at the time
was it Polk I can't remember he was like
nah we're not going to keep Mexico we're
gonna give Mexico back and people in
America were actually very much in favor
of keeping it after we won that war and
if we did would there be a big problem
with cartels now I'm not seriously
suggesting that we invade other
countries but fair question if the
United States did keep Mexico after that
war yeah would there be a problem with
cartels and crime and all that stuff I
don't think so I think there'd still be
massive demand for drugs I mean that's a
big problem I mean as long as there's
demand there's going to be Supply that's
the problem but right now the challenge
we're dealing with is look drugs have
been bad they've always been bad it's a
bad idea to take them in my opinion uh
but now they're being poisoned with
fentanyl right and so what where's the
fentanyl coming from it's coming from
China and you look I just got to think
we got to stop that we're voting on
bills today and look thankfully this is
now bipartisan stopping the fentanyl
because you know there's a girl in my
district Lizzie Murphy 21 years old took
a Xanax at a party bad idea but it was
laced with fentanyl one pill one party
killed her right and so that's happened
in tens of thousands of times like 70
000 Americans dead with fentanyl and to
your point if we had control of Mexico
look there might still be cartels
supplying something but we would not
have this kind of crisis on our hands
today and that's part of the challenge
today since uh you know the question is
can we unite to deal with this problem
and so many others
without conquering
oh hopefully without contouring do you
think we can
uh I I think they're I think we can I'm
certainly not calling for an invasion of
Mexico
we would probably not lose what about
but I don't know what's war in Iraq if
this was all business I mean Canada we
would have already acquired them right I
mean but you know they have like 40 50
million people I mean it would be a
pretty easy acquisition uh they would
have better government than they have
today on the other hand look they've got
Trudeau and all this socialism cancel
culture Galore all kinds of the you know
Utopia that the far left in America
wants I would trade one far left uh
person who wants to fundamentally remake
America with critical theory Marxism for
one you know Freedom loving Canadian
well I mean I might I might give you a
10 for one deal you can have 10 of these
far left crazy people uh for one like
Freedom loving Canadian Canada
or Venezuelan or trying to escape people
who are like hey communism is bad
America is the dream and they want to be
here we're better off with just travel
just travel I feel like we are on the
cusp of of of the end of the American
military-industrial complex or at least
that's one option and I'm I'm really
like considering like if that does
happen and we become just the United
States of isolationism what's what are
we going to do like when another country
starts taking over its neighbors well so
this is an interesting question
so I want to mention something there's
this phrase like isolationism and I
understand at least this is just sort of
the term people use politically but I
don't think not getting involved in Wars
is
accurately described as isolationism
right like you're not I mean if you're
still trading with other countries if
you have pro-social interactions with
other countries you're not isolated
you're just not fighting them I think
with the question of other countries
being invaded there's a real question
there there's a real concern because
there are human rights violations all
over the world but then also there are
human rights violations all over the
world I mean how do we decide which ones
we get involved who has the most
resources we can acquire that's why I'm
like it's just it's just all Bs we're
not invading China over there of their
concentration camps look at Eisenhower
though go back to Eisenhower look he he
didn't get caught an isolationist he
ended the you know pushed for the end of
the uh Korean War you know it ended you
know as he was campaigning to be
president but you know you look you look
at you look at uh winding that war down
he could have continued it and waged it
uh at the end of World War II is the
last time we had as much debt as we have
today right and and we knew like you
can't you can't have that much debt
relative to the size of your economy so
the entire Global monetary system was
reset and everyone knew you have to pay
down the debt so Eisenhower said we
can't get involved everywhere you have
to be focused and I think that's the
time we're in today uh we have to
convince people look you can't live with
this much debt and even if you say oh we
can print more money well haven't we
just tested this that no well you can
print some money but you're not going to
be able to buy the same amount of stuff
inflation is real right and so you can't
just print your way out of this you
actually have to get back to the
discipline and focus that scarcity
produces and you know uh frankly
Republic uh keeps you that way but if
you want to try to build an Empire
that's why Empires fail is because they
over consume the resources that they've
got thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time